hi everybody it's Friday yeah it's like
I keep trying could like said and then
he's going to start [ __ ] talking
that's how we do this shot good movie
last night yeah that's kind of what I
want to talk I wake up II did that dude
as well because I knew I'd heard about
him we got to do a show on him we should
because that's what I was thinking when
I was reading through his Wikipedia page
I'm like yeah this guy needs a whole
episode yeah he's getting in like we did
some crazy [ __ ] oh yeah in the red light
oh pretty
yeah Sophie sent us a yoga movie called
Bronson it's called Bronson get out of
there and look at her she's denying his
life like that's a new one okay we had
all this pretty light set up in that
book he came in like allow me to [ __ ]
all over there yeah England had this
guy's nameless he caught himself Charles
Bronson yes and he's [ __ ] most
lunatic resident violent criminal no a
murderer though no and I would he wasn't
that much of a criminal he was just more
a prisoner and he just did it but well
the shitty Debbie did in prison mostly
and all this [ __ ] that he got caught for
was just like armed robbery and stuff
like which is bad I'm not saying it's
not but he wasn't like a serial killer
or anything it just seemed like he would
get caught for something get like a
two-year five-year sentence or something
like that in like 20 and then he would
like caused so much ruckus in prison by
like beating up guards beating up other
prisoners taking people hostage all this
other kind of stuff that he would get
more time added to his sentence right
and with it's pretty actually the [ __ ]
that he did outside while he was free
was child's play compared to what he was
doing inside yeah I think he seemed to
genuinely enjoy being in prison he's
insane yeah I don't think he was stupid
though because I mean I was kind of
thinking
because you have to think that the movie
and actually the movie was older than I
thought when I looked it up earlier it
came out in 2008 okay Tom party isn't it
yeah and he's working great in this yeah
you guys want to see if it's a good
limit if you guys want to see if you
liked Clockwork Orange this is very
Clockwork Orange it's yeah it's almost
kind of like a sequel to Clockwork
Orange in a way it's a big clock or
Gorge omage it's got the same tone it's
got voiceovers all the classical music
it's it's very much like clockwork
orange' style yeah and the character is
like something out of damn Clockwork
Orange he's like something out of that
damn book yeah you know I read that book
is a good book it was yeah and he is in
like Alex crazier crazier than Alex but
I'm interested in his psychology and
like now that I started reading about
him on the wood because the movie is you
know highly stylized
and it's loosely based on his life and
actually they left a lot of stuff out
he's still alive nowadays yeah and a lot
of [ __ ] happens subsequently no you know
after the movie came out even but he
still locked up yeah yeah let him go
that's what I well the fascinating thing
about him is that it seemed that the
authorities in the UK after a time they
were just like they had no idea like
what to do with him because they had
never encountered anyone like this
before like I said he's not a serial
killer
he was like mostly started out as like a
petty criminal but then every time he
got caught he would just like do this
really [ __ ] up [ __ ] in jail just so he
could either stay in there longer or he
just seemed to like enjoy it I guess at
the time that the movie came out he had
done I think 34 years in prison yeah
yeah an insane asylum off of basically a
six-year sentence and 30 years of that
34 year sentence was done in solitary
confinement yeah I found out later
that's like a crash dummy at every turn
he made things worse for himself it was
almost kind of like masochism and say to
man maybe that's what it was and why he
is
like he loves to beep to punish others
and to punish himself like he had no he
didn't want any privileges he wanted
everything taken away he wanted
everything to be harder and harder and
harder just nuts you know
prisoners tend to be easy to control the
more time you they have to serve usually
the better condition here in the US the
better conditions they give them and the
more privileges they give them that way
you have something to take away yeah and
most guys who are locked up if they're
with 30 life sentences 30 34 year
sentences a lot of them do pretty good
time you do your research or at least
you can go online and guys will talk
about prison and what the prison scene
is like you can't have a guy locked up
with nothing to lose he becomes too
[ __ ] dangerous well yeah the bigger
the senate's the more usually they give
that guy they give him a reason to live
because they don't want him to run
around kill staff and then he becomes a
danger to others to everybody here know
and you can't lock them all up in
solitary confinement just tens and
hundreds of thousands of them here in
the United States or two like that
because there's millions of people
locked up most of its small [ __ ] but
there's hundreds and hundreds of
thousands of [ __ ] life sentence dudes
and that's a sizable portion you know of
the prison population and it would be
real expensive and it would be
unrealistic to keep each one of them
locked it aside locked up in solitary
confinement besides they have families
and their families would protest it yeah
and do in their lawyers would get I mean
they're still human being yeah I mean I
would argue like yes we've done some
shows about some serial killers that I
would argue you they should just throw
goods now be Louisiana Louisiana's
biggest heavy-duty penitentiary would be
Angola and Angola is where they send the
lifers or guys with [ __ ] huge
sentences it was originally kind of like
a sugarcane plantation and it was like
something out of an Angola you know you
know a place where you know
you have black people out in the field
working sugarcane plantations because
back in the seventeen hundreds us what
it was like yeah no but Angola today you
can go online and look at it is famous
for say if it's rate rodeo that's like
something those guys really would
respire aspire to is to be one of the
rodeo clowns yeah or a [ __ ] rodeo
rider they make a lot of money and it's
kind of like going to see a damn what do
you call it like a damn gladiatori
[ __ ] event you know gladiators out in
an arena and they have these [ __ ]
crazy-ass competitions you know that
these prisoners want to do dress up as a
damn clown and try to take a
hundred-dollar bill off the forehead of
a [ __ ] bull yeah
or they set up a damn poker table and
you sit there and all dressed up as
clowns and let the bull go and the last
man to get up from the table Lou a wins
so you know I mean they're all trying to
not get up and they're not being forced
to do this they [ __ ] work to become
rodeo star or a clown they want to do
that remember we saw that movie which
was a fictional movie probably like
sometime last year but it was based on a
true thing called the Mustang and it was
about like that was I think that was out
in Arizona or New Mexico or something
like that where they had these prison
programs where they have the prisoners
like train the horses like break the
mustangs and like how rodeos and stuff
like that because you know some of these
they have to have something to do and
they have to have something to aspire to
you know there's gonna be a very small
percentage like I said you roll hardcore
serial killers or Psychopaths that
aren't going to respond to that but I
think most prisoners would respond to me
I think and it makes them like like you
said it makes them easier to control it
makes a lot of you it's not so much a
danger to the people that have work in
the prison's and deal with them and then
goal is like I said it's it's a
plantation-style prison it doesn't
really look like a prison it looks more
like a town it does have fences but they
get to walk around there's no way out of
there yeah you know I mean unless you
have a vehicle and then some of them are
actually turned into like Class A
trustees or they drive trucks across the
state for the state which is and saying
when you think about it but no they do
have
prisoners with life sentences that
they'll let drive a truck across the
state yeah which you know they're
supervised but they're still doing it
yeah ya know so it's it's it's odd when
you run across a story about a guy like
Charles Bronson that he would have a big
sentence like that or actually start off
with a small sentence yeah I think his
first sentence was only yeah it was six
like eight years so I got yeah it was it
was fairly minor yeah and he has a small
sentence and then he goes out and does
whatever he can do to turn it into a
bigger sentence and then he makes the
incarceration more intensive yeah if he
enjoys it
or there's something can't control he
can't control himself yeah
so they did Connor to him what they did
what they would do in the United States
they would assume that he was insane
they said to a damn insane asylum well
he's he's served time in three yeah
different including Broadmoor they're
very famous he served time ultimately in
like three different the three big you
know criminally insane hospital yeah in
the UK he served time in all of them
yeah in the u.s. they would just find
him in saying they would say you're
[ __ ] insane
yeah they throw him throw him in a
mental and once you get into something
like that there's no sentence to stir
serve you might be there forever yeah
that's the thing because we were talking
about this last night because I was like
well if you get sent I know that like a
lot of prisoners depending on what kind
of sentence they're looking at what
prison they're going to the various
other things it's like maybe going to a
mental hospital would be better in the
sense that you might have more room you
might have more privileges you take
drugs yeah you gets it free drugs
whatever yeah um however there is
another thing where if they send you to
a mental asylum there's no end game here
you might not let out at some point but
you might not it kind of like depends on
how it goes yet to be declared it's
saying yeah so it's not a kind of thing
where oh your sentence is over you're
free now you're just like oh well maybe
you'll get out and maybe you won't yeah
you know so it's kind of a trade-off but
this guy really did seem you know and
when I read about him like I said they
didn't go into this in the movie but
later on like he wrote a bunch of books
his art you know because they kind of
went a little bit into like him doing
our thing you know his arts been
auctioned off like for charity and stuff
like that he's considered like an
outsider artist one of the funniest
things is that it's so funny but it's
kind of funny and [ __ ] that way was that
one of the books that he wrote because
he's like a big fitness advocate you
know it's like you know working out and
everything one of his books is about the
best ways to exercise in confined spaces
oh yeah well that may be especially yeah
write what you know that's what he knows
how to do he knows that he's just like
in a tiny [ __ ] how to workout without
any weights yeah that - it's like so he
that's like his specialty probably
standing on his head a lot and doing
handstand
I would have push-ups like that but yeah
he's done like a whole bunch of that's
kind of like his area of expertise
because Oh his fighting style he'd take
all his clothes off and oil himself up
so he's harder to grasp his [ __ ] leg
like a greasy little [ __ ] Tom Hardy's
[ __ ] with his little crooked [ __ ]
hung out in the bottle [ __ ] yeah yeah
ladies are or or gay men of whatever if
you want to see Tom Hardy naked this is
me he's naked after this movie yeah
evidently Bronson was straight but he
had a lot of gays support yeah you know
gay dudes were trying to help him you
know on the inside and out and never
really say whether or not he was messing
with the gay dudes that he probably was
I'm thinking probably yeah he really
didn't seem that they were they seemed
to he seemed to have a lot of them
wrapped around his fingers yeah you know
though he didn't like the whole
underground Fight Club say again like a
lot of I guess there was one at that
dude in prison yeah remember yeah and
that guy got out later and got out later
and helped him in another strange
underground Fight Club
he's fighting even Kotak dogs yeah guys
are that which that's some crazy [ __ ]
yeah and also they didn't mention this
in the movie either but he was like
maybe and maybe this is where I had
heard of him before because I was
reading about the the craze you know
Reggie and Ronnie Kray the very famous
twin brother gangsters in the UK
probably the most famous gangsters in UK
history but he was a friend of theirs
like her an associate of their so that's
probably where I had heard him for
because we were watching the movie and
I'm going I know this dude I'm like I
have heard of this dude but I couldn't
remember like
reading about him specifically so I must
have read about him like in the course
of researching something else probably
when I was reading about the craze I
heard about it or like what a murderer
maybe that I was so really what prior it
will probably do a review of this movie
eventually so this really isn't a review
of the movie it's just a heads up and a
recommendation to watch this movie
called Bronson it's weird it's a weird
baby it's very stylized yeah and a very
good movie yeah I mean Jenny did I even
once look at my tablet you did not not
even once that much like I said that's
something and I was like going the
music's great the edits great sometimes
like it jumps back and forth so
sometimes I got a little bit confused
yeah it was not a straight biopic by any
means but I just felt like I was
watching another installment of like a
Clockwork Orange yeah it really did I
mean even if I were 10 minutes into the
movie I was just like wow this is like
Clockwork Orange
yeah like the tone of it's very similar
and I don't think it's just because it's
like this super violent like British
prison system type of thing that has
classical music it definitely on Moz is
it though well there was one scene in
particular where I said [ __ ] it now yeah
marchin already does that cool you know
like a look you know for the [ __ ]
prison warden whatever the voice-over
the edit just everything him telling his
story it just was kind of like it's not
like Alex telling it to you it's just
like it's from that same genre yeah you
could watch the movies back to back and
go yeah all right like it wasn't yeah
it's like it's like a crime genre yeah
the Clockwork Orange genre yeah it would
make a good double feature yeah they
[ __ ] I tell you what I don't know
about nowadays but you know when I was
you know when I was living over there
and when I was kind of um you know
reading a lot about [ __ ] that was going
on over there man they love their crime
movies and crime stories and stuff like
that there is there is kind of an
undercurrent I guess in American
folklore as well there is an
undercurrent of like anti-heroes with
like a lot of criminals not so not those
serial killers and [ __ ] like that they
have kind of the same relationship with
serial killers we have over here where
it's kind of like people like hearing
about them but they're not lionize
necessarily however they do seem to have
like a romanticized thing about people
that were kind of like outlaws like bank
robbers that type of stuff where what I
mean you can do you can yeah
Bry because you can't cultures kind of
kind of little bit conformist I'd say
Authority itself well I don't know it's
kind of hard to say I don't I never
really got that impression when I was
there like in the 90s late 90s early
2000s it seemed like the the perception
that people had of the UK like in the
United States was something that was
like an old person thing over there you
know what I mean like I only encountered
that like an older put like Graham like
people my grandparents age um my people
my own age and like you know younger
than yeah there's a certain aspect
there's certain aspects that I didn't
really get that if there are certain
aspects to British culture though just
just that just wouldn't fly here I mean
think of it look at law enforcement look
at the difference yeah you know British
cops don't have guns
okay some of them don't the ones that
I've seen on TV don't there are but
there are going to have armed branches
that do yeah there are but if they kind
of call them out only an emergency don't
think well only in a particular case
where it would be called for they don't
were all him out for anything because
most of the shit's minor you couldn't
you couldn't you couldn't have that
United States if a cop is unarmed then
he's a dead man basically well yeah I
guess I don't know where it is I mean
like I said just go go all right I'm
gonna talk about it there's a go on a
channel on YouTube called police
activity and watch all the damn police
shootings and everything that [ __ ]
police here have to deal with it's
absolutely insane
I just saw one and see their today or
yesterday I don't remember a dude calls
the cops and said and says I was walking
down the street and a guy hit me in the
back of the head with a sword and the
person is like are you bleeding and he
goes and I don't think he was he says
now be hit in the back of the head of
the sword he's just walking down the
street cops show up they see the guy
he's starting to hide in the bushes the
cop said hey come on here [ __ ]
that's what the cop said
came out and charged him and pulled a
sword out and [ __ ] ran right towards
that cops that cops is sucking of course
have already had a gun pulled on him
probably shot him about six times in the
chest before that guy hit the ground and
when he hit just he just you can see it
just hit like a sack of [ __ ] but it's
just that the cops here deal with
insanity its total insanity
even if you have a gun pointed at these
guys they'll attack you well but yeah
bat dude sounded like a total lunatic
but there's lots of them well yeah on
that channel you'll see that same theme
over and over and over again out of most
of those shootings it's an an unarmed or
a semi armed man running directly at the
cops through and in through a hail of
[ __ ] gunfire [ __ ] that a sane person
just would never do I feel like a lot of
times that's either drugs and/or suicide
by cop yeah could be a combo of both
thanks yeah or just you know yeah yeah
you know or a lunatic right could be all
three of those things
all of them are mutually exclusive and
it's totally understandable if you were
in the position of these cops why they
just [ __ ] they just shoot first
because that's what they're they just
see that over and over and over again
and they're in their training you know
you give a cop any [ __ ] here he's
assumes you're gonna [ __ ] attack him
yeah probably yeah and just YouTube it's
called police activity look at that
channel you will just be [ __ ]
appalled and some of the stupid [ __ ]
these dudes do to get it to get shot
yeah you know well like I said it seems
like they want to get shot or they don't
know what's going on okay you want to
get shot I can't make a generalization
because you know you're gonna get shot
yeah I just can't make out a no I can't
make a generalization you know and
they're getting shot over a cop just
questioning them over something that
wouldn't barely be a yes some of the
time since some of the shootings what
the guy did would be like a very
low-level misdemeanor and then probably
not gonna even get arrested for you know
I mean but still they just
do a kamikaze attack on the cop or
something a lot of times in a case like
that
it might be that that person is guilty
of something much worse
and is afraid maybe that the police were
caught because look it because look at
some [ __ ] like ah you're right no look
at some [ __ ] like some serial killers
yeah that you know they they operate
with impunity for 10 20 years but then
they get caught doing some minor [ __ ]
but there'll be a whole description
right underneath the video where what
the actual situation was and after the
investigations really the person just
and what it boils down to is the person
was stupid yes it wasn't wanted we have
a person in a shortage of I just said I
didn't say that that was histah the
average reason is because they're stupid
it doesn't have anything to do with
crime so they know I just said that that
could be a factor and yeah in some of
them that's all we're pride talking like
maybe you know on the in that channel
whenever it's mentioned that me me like
maybe 5% of them miletto they said I
just said that might be a factor in some
of the cases somebody that was a factor
in all of them no I mean most of them is
just what did I say did I say five
minutes ago I said they could either be
lunatics or on drugs or they just wanted
to get shot like suicide I guess they
just want to get like in a small
medication it might be somebody that did
some work [ __ ] and didn't want to get
caught because when these dudes get shot
you can tell they don't want to get shot
because sometimes are twisting and
turning and trying to dodge the bullets
or when they do get shot they're
surprised that they got shot they turn
around and go oh ma and then they start
woe is me before they die maybe they
think they have super don't like they
had super power and that they got shot
and then oh wow should have done that oh
why did you shoot me
well everybody dude at a damn [ __ ]
axe in his hand or something why'd you
shoot me and just it's [ __ ] stupid
it's stupid
well yeah I'm denying that people are
stupid [ __ ] dumb a lot of people are
stupid for nothing yeah yeah but but you
know the thing about it and how we got
into this whole situation will or
conversation was that this guy
kind of fascinates me because he doesn't
seem stupid he may very well be crazy um
Charlie Bronson which I said that's not
his real name what was his real name
Michael Peterson right I think his real
name but he's changed it since then like
a couple of times now he wants to be
known as Charles Salvador because he
named himself after Salvador Dali so I
don't know if he legally changed it to
that but that's what he wants to be
changed so I think this is the third or
fourth name change but uh he did that
back in 2014 apparently but he just
fascinated me because he could have just
done you know a feat a couple of year
sentence for whatever the you know
initial crime was it was usually like
assault like I said armed robbery stuff
like that which like I said it's not
good but it's not you're not gonna get
like a life in prison for that but he
just kept causing trouble and he just
did it very deliberately yeah it seemed
like he was very deliberately it was
sadomasochism I think it was and that's
what kind of what makes him so
fascinating is he really seemed to enjoy
the experience of being in prison the
experience of getting in fights like
this kind of excitement and experience
of being punished of yeah of punishing
others and being punished himself they
asked him what he was want what he would
want
what is it you want from us what do you
want us to do for you like he would take
people hostage in and make demands and
they said what do you want and you'd be
like [ __ ] off yeah no he didn't want
anything you know what I don't know if
he could just not articulate it I'm I
just I don't think he wanted anything he
didn't want anything he just wanted some
action he wanted a what he wanted a
change a change yeah maybe to go to
another cell maybe to go to another
prison maybe that you know something
something to change in the environment
yeah that's what he wanted he seemed
like he constantly needed like some need
to go somewhere else in the simulation I
want to go to this prison I want to go
to that chart [ __ ] I wanted to be famous
too and yeah remember whenever they were
transferred him he'd be walking out with
like fanfare of the other prisoners yeah
so I think cuz he would like beat up
guards issues yes I think the attention
that he got from and the attention and
the approval that he got from the other
prisoners I think was part of his yeah
yeah
Chansey kajita fight and he could take
this punishment and that he was a man
and they were all [ __ ] that's what
yeah but yeah it's it's a really really
good movie yeah and um you know like I
said we might do a movie retrospective
on it cuz I'm it's like I said it's
older than I yeah initially thought if I
haven't reviewed the actual movie yeah
that's part of the movie we're just just
making recommendation at this point yeah
and we were more talking about like the
real guy because the movie is like I
said it's very loosely based on his play
for whatever yeah so uh what's today
it's Friday right
yeah yeah head of the pack has just got
delivered to the door oh okay I heard
wearing if you didn't hear it ring bell
no because you were probably talking it
was side wrap around an outfit you are
about stances alright so we're gonna
wrap it up cuz we gotta do a couple more
things and we probably got a record a
long show tonight tonight so we got to
get ready to bolster our livers and get
ready for tonight's show
yeah I got some more research I got to
do and [ __ ] like that so have a good
rest of your Friday we'll talk to you
guys again tomorrow